[Music]
1938 we're playing 1948
and e4
okay let's play
let's play an alicorn
which is
just a generally underrated opening at
this level i think
okay but unfortunately our opponent
plays knight c3 so he doesn't go into
you know the main line of d5
so here there are two choices e5
transposes into the vienna but if you
want to play
like a genuine alakan player then you
should play d5
and transpose into a a favorable version
of the scandi like if you're a genuine
alakan player you go for this position
ed5 knight d5
bishop c4 the knight drops back to b6
with tempo he takes on d5 okay
this doesn't seem too impressive to me
i like in yeah and in this position
we we kind of have like a scandi but
white can't go knight c3 because that
knight is gone so the queen is actually
quite safe in the center
and i don't know exactly what the theory
is here i think black has many different
ways of developing pieces
like we can play a little bit more
positionally we can play g6 bishop g7
but i think if we want to play very
ambitiously we can aim for a long castle
i think we can aim for long castle and
we can do that just by developing the
the queen side pieces as quickly as
possible yeah so the bishop will come to
g4
and the knight will come to c6
and then we're going to castle queenside
so i think we can start with bishop g4
just to try to induce bishop b2 now
knight c6
and then we castle queenside
bang
and i think black is a very nice
position because we can also play e5 to
control more of the center
so there's an upside and a downside to
going e5 here
we could go more modestly e6
and then
play bishop d6 in order to hit the h2
pawn
but given that white has positioned his
pawn
quite passively with d3
i think e5 makes a lot of sense to grab
as much space in the center as possible
bishop e3
now let's make uh
well actually king b8 walks into a very
strange tactic knight takes c5
okay so i want to play king b8 at some
point that's just something we'll keep
in mind i think we should keep expanding
i think we should keep expanding
uh and perhaps play the move f5
just expanding on the king side
yeah bishop d6 is also possible this is
one of those positions where
you know there's like three or four
moves that i think are about equivalent
in strength and so you shouldn't spend
you know too long trying to nitpick you
should just make natural moves in such a
position
yeah the bishop is probably going to
come out to d6 in order to over protect
the e5 pawn and in case we ever go e4
it's gonna be a good idea to keep the
bishop on d6 he goes knight g5
which i thought
white would play
okay we'll take the bishop on e2
and what should we do now
what move should we make now yeah we
should just play h6
yeah get the knight kick the knight out
of g5
my my guess is that our opponent might
be intending c4
but c4 i believe just blunders upon due
to queen takes d3 and there is no fork
because the queen on e2 hangs
and this is like a classic concept c4
queen takes d3 and if he queen trades
then knight f7 is no longer a fork
okay so the knight goes back to f3
okay
so who can propose a good move now
one good move is to complete our
development with bishop d6 but as many
of you guys are indicating i like the
move g5 continuing to expand on the king
side starting to shove our pawns down
the board and we're creating also a nice
development square for our dark squared
bishop on g7
now you might say well isn't the bishop
on g7 just sort of staring at our own
pawn well yes it is but it's also really
solidifying our position and like i said
earlier at some point we might push our
e pawn down to e4
that's not an unlikely possibility and
if that happens then we would love for
our bishop to be sitting on the long
diagonal
and also our pawns are just doing a
great job of controlling a bunch of
different squares
so i think what's important in this
position is for us to play without
hurrying we need to keep improving
and we shouldn't push our pawns for no
reason and prematurely so for example a
move that i don't particularly like is
f4
because it gives away this e4 square
which is a stronghold that white can use
to keep the pawns at bay
so what i do like here is either bishop
d6 as mentioned earlier or bishop g7 i
think either move is good
but let's play bishop d6 let's let's
arrange our pieces more more in the
center yeah bishop d6 just seems
a little bit more harmonious to me now
notice that we're not afraid of c4
we're absolutely unafraid of c4 bishop
back to d2 okay
so now i can guarantee
that knight d4 is probably on your mind
right now but i actually don't want to
play that move why not because it you
have the immediate dopamine hit of
attacking the queen
but then the queen drops back to d1
and what's gonna happen then is that
white's gonna play c3 and kick the
knight away and weirdly
this is gonna help white because the
queen from d1
can then activate to a4
so rather than doing anything immediate
let's continue improving our position by
bringing another piece into the center
rook he8 bishop c3 okay so our opponent
is just kind of going back and forth
giving us all of the time in the world
to make as many improvements to our
position as we can possibly manage
there's one more thing we haven't fully
done yet now i like the move g4
now i like the move g4 because it takes
away
the f3 square from white's pieces and
why is that important because that's the
knight on e1's only square now the
knight on e1 is totally out of
commission and
we have this idea which is slow
but still quite dangerous of pushing the
h-bond down the board
which i think that we should now apply
because we've made all of the
improvements to our position
and now we can actually start attacking
let's play h5
d4 is not a threat because that square
is under our control
and we're
yeah so
save the questions for after the game he
goes g3
okay now there are a bunch of tempting
moves in this position
hmm
so
conceptually
this is a super interesting ooh
there's a interesting subtlety here yeah
we should definitely play h4
we should definitely play h4 i was
calculating what happens after knight g2
which i think white is going to play
because if if white takes on h4 then
clearly we've benefited from
from what has happened
no the bishop on d6 is quite good yeah
knight g2 now i think it's very
important to play accurately
so
i think a lot of you are probably
thinking let's go h3 and check mate him
on g2
but if you calculate the actual
variation then
there's a bit of an issue which is that
after h3
white goes knight e3
and our queen cannot stay on this
diagonal every square is defended e4
i'll do it in a different color f3 and
g2 and h1 are all protected
so we're going to have to drop our queen
back to f7
that's totally not the end of the world
but it's going to take a while for us
to get our queen back to d5 and i'll
show you why i find that to be
concerning
so we have a very smart move here
instead of going h3 immediately
we first play the move knight d4 which i
know a lot of you
you know it's been on your radar for a
while but now is the time to play it the
point is that after the trade yes we
open the e file and we attack the queen
but the most important part is that we
defend the e3 square which means the
knight can no longer jump to e3 which
means that h3 is going to be a terribly
strong move
because knight f4 we can take it knight
e3 we can take it the knight will have
to go to h4 and then white is really
hanging by a thread because if we manage
to take that knight we're gonna have
possibility of checkmate on g2
okay knight h4 but the game is far from
over we need to find a way to eliminate
this knight that's the objective so we
have a couple of ways to do that one is
to try to do it with our rook
the other is to try to do it with our
bishop i think that we should do it with
our bishop this is not gg by the way
this is this game is far from over
i think that we should actually wait a
second let me think
yes i think we should do it with our
bishop
and after the game i will explain why
but in the interest of time for now
we're going to play bishop e7
we are threatening bishop takes h4 white
has to push the f-bomb only move
if it doesn't push yep f4
now we take on h4
and we transform our advantage this is
the hard part because we've made a
couple of moves just now with the aim of
checkmating him on g2 and it may seem
that our strategy has failed but
in fact it has succeeded because in
forcing our opponent to defend against
the mate threat we've induced tremendous
weaknesses in white's position which we
can now use and one of those weaknesses
is of course these squares along the e
file that we now occupy this is a really
sexy move rookie three totally automatic
we double on the e file and
the fact that g2 is
defended isn't important because white
is completely tied down to that square
okay and this is the decisive mistake
white had to go rook de1
we could even take on c3 if we wanted to
that one's the game on the spot
actually i like dc3
yeah let's play dc3 because because
queen takes e3 gets mated
and if b takes c3
then we have a very pretty final move
yeah we could have also played rook
takes d3 but i think this is even more
accurate
because after bc3 we play rook take c3
and we win the rook on d1
and now very elegantly
rook takes d3 ends the game
yeah just
pure
and again we're using the g2 square as
as you know to tie white's pieces down
i think this game shows that
it's not only about you know using a
checkmating square to deliver checkmate
you can use the checkmating square to
tie down decisively tie down your
opponent's defenses
chef's kiss yeah cool
nice game
i mean white played i think quite poorly
overall but nonetheless i think it was
instructive so we decided to play the
alkyne
knight c3
so knight c3 is is frequently considered
like the you know the cop-out move
i mean obviously what's up simon thank
you for the 20 months
and e5 of course is
is the move
gasper simon thank you for the prime two
different simons
okay knight c3 d5 right d5 is again like
a good version of the scandi
and there's a bunch of theory here like
there's the move e5
and
black has a bunch of moves here okay d4
is the most well known
but knight fd7 also exists you can
transpose into a french potentially
if you play like this
so
even knight e4 is a move here so you can
explore this on your own
i won't delve into the
the theory white takes on d5 and as far
as i know
knight takes d5 is quite rare and for
very good reason thank you shak chichel
for the prime
the main move here is bishop c4
attacking the knight
and then the knight drops back to b6 you
have bishop b3
and then
there are a couple of moves bourdnik
plays this position with black all the
time i think he goes c5
trying to push c4
d3 knight c6 you get this kind of
position
and then
black can also play the immediate knight
c6
knight f3 and then like bishop f5 and e6
so you get
basically this type of position black is
very very solid here i think this is
supposed to be very close to equal
or or totally equal
so this is not the way that white should
challenge the alakan
but okay knight d5
i actually think if anything black might
be contending already for a slightly
better position
because this queen is on a great square
it's totally unassailable it's
incredibly hard to attack
i think if you're a beginner it's
important to point out that moves like
c4 are completely not scary
because
not only does this ruin
you know and destroy the
prospects for white's light squared
bishop but it creates this gaping hole
on d4
that we can later occupy with our knight
so we just drop the queen back or d6 or
d8 and then we can focus on
gaining control of the d4 square
okay so knight f3
bishop g4 bishop b2 knight c6 we're
developing our pieces
yeah and d3 is is quite bad i think i
think if white wants to play ambitiously
the only serious move is d4
and then we were planning to castle but
now white experiences problems with the
d4 pawn
because after c3
if you play
scandi like openings you should know
what black's move is in a position like
this what should black do here
you can also find this move by
identifying this as a pawn chain
and then realizing that the the key to
the kingdom for black is to play e5 yeah
this is quite typical in such positions
you break down the pawn chain
and all of the complications here are in
black's favor just because of how active
our pieces are
if d e
then there's this move queen e4
attacking the queen pinning the bishop
knight is coming into e5 thank you dude
for the sub this is really really bad
for white
if d4 there why not take the knight and
pawn oh that's a good question so if you
take the knight and take the pawn
uh this is a trick you have to know
because the what is the queen defended
by it's defended by the knight but the
bishop is making contact with the knight
so it can take with check
you have to take back and you lose the
queen
this is a concept that exists in many
many different openings
so castle c3 you go e5 and you develop a
big initiative
in the game
in the game white played
uh d3
so we castle white castles we play e5
what was the tactic preventing king via
yeah yeah so
any time and i've i've literally talked
about this a gazillion times
but every time there's a slightly
different tactic anytime you have this
standoff this situation
you need to watch out for a very
particular kind of tactic that tactic
happens when the knight on f3 moves out
of the way and because the bishop on g4
is undefended problems arise as a result
there's this move knight takes e5
and you might ask well
how does the king being unbeated have
anything to do with this well here's the
point
if
white does that here
then we can simply play bishop takes e2
and queen takes e2 as forced and then we
take the knight with the piece but with
the king on b8 knight takes c6 is check
bishop p2 this move is check you can't
take the queen and that's why
i refrain from that move then white
takes back the bishop and his upper pawn
so
it says vision zog and it's very very
easy to miss this stuff so for that
reason
and this is one of the motivating
factors behind f5 it also defends the
bishop on g4 which means that we can now
play moves like king b8
although
an instructive little point
is that after a3 i think king b8 is
actually still pretty bad
and can somebody tell me why
white can play a very clever move here
so you might say oh it's knight takes e5
but it's not because now the pawn
defends the bishop we can just take back
but
white can use this
to induce a concession
no bishop g5 doesn't do anything i just
move the rook
yeah very good h3
h3 is very clever because if you play
bishop h5 then once again the bishop is
undefended you can take on e5
you might say well that's not a problem
i'll take the knight but you don't want
to give away the light squared bishop
here i mean look at white's bishops now
white's bishop is on an excellent square
and this is a very undesirable trade for
black
so this is a good example of using
tactics to induce
a favorable trade now maybe black can
play h5 here and try for like a fishing
pole idea i'm not sure
but
you know this isn't something i would
want to
necessarily mess around with
but you might be surprised at how often
even very strong players miss tactics on
this diagonal
it's it's literally like a constant and
there's many different types of tactics
i've shown a game many times
on stream where a very strong i am
blundered upon just like this
against me
and and it's variations on the theme
essentially here it is
yeah this is budapest 2010
i'm playing a guy who has the same
rating as me
in this position i played the move
knight f6 is obviously king's indian
and after about five minutes my opponent
thank you j twitch then plays bishop g5
black to play
what should black do this is almost a
trick question because if you just pair
it what i just talked about you're going
to be wrong
if you just if you just parrot the move
that we discussed you're going to be
wrong
very good you guys got it it's not
knight takes e4 which is which is a very
clever move
but who can tell me why it's not knight
takes e4
doesn't this also win a pawn yeah knight
takes d5 is correct
yeah white plays knight takes c4
f takes c4 and now bishop takes c7 you
have to take back white takes on e4 and
white is
fine does that make sense and so the
move is actually knight takes d5 which
was missed by white
and the same it's this concept of the
same knight that takes the pawn is also
defending the bishop so bishop b7
there's 97.
so my opponent ended up going like
bishop h6 and i ultimately won the game
so
yeah anyways yeah this tactic is super
common back to the game so knight g5
okay here we
we play simple simple chess we take it
we go h6
push the knight back expand on the king
side
develop the bishop to d6 instructive
moment here i think a lot of people
resist
moves like this because you think the
bishop just stares at the pawn but
that's not a good rule to develop pieces
by like you shouldn't just develop on a
quote-unquote open square
pieces like this can can actually be
tremendously strong in fact this bishop
kind of won us the game later on
right it's about the long-term placement
of the pieces and in the long run
you can
take it almost for granted that one of
these pawns is going to push forward the
bishop is going to be useful here thank
you thirsty monster appreciate the raid
okay bishop d2 i don't really know what
our opponent was doing here
but notice that we just patiently bring
all of our pieces onto good squares rook
he8
why not the other rook to eat well
because the other rook is on a nice file
i don't know i just figured the
coordination is really really good this
way
so a lot of people here were itching to
play e4 and it is possible that e4 is
even stronger than what i played
but i thought it might be premature
so you could do this
but i don't think it's quite as scary
for white as it appears although no it
is scary it is scary
if queen f3 then there's g4
and we're tossing white's pieces around
and here i guess you could drop your
queen back to f7 and threaten a
discovery against white's queen
no this is really really good i agree
i agree this this would have been this
would have been tremendously strong as
well
well queen h5 there's rook h4
if queen h5 there's this move
so the queen literally has no squares
question how did you decide between f5
and h5 earlier
so rewind rewind rewind rewind
uh
well if you compare i think h5 does the
same thing that f5 does it defends the
bishop but f5 has the added benefit as
you're saying of controlling key central
squares and also preparing e4
and potentially preparing f4 it's just a
more multi-faceted move okay back to the
game
so yes e4 would have been strong but i i
was kind of intent on pushing our king
side pawns so h5 hopefully this idea
makes sense to people i'm trying to push
the pawn to h3 create that potential
mating square on g2
white is totally paralyzed
now h4
again f4
would have given up the e4 square which
i really didn't want to do because the
last thing we would want here is the
queen trade
so h4
and after knight g2 comes the critical
moment of the game
where you need to find this move knight
d4 so the logic once again is that you
want to play h3 that's the ideal setup
but thank you thirsty
but
white plays 93
and chases the queen away
and after queen f7 white i believe has
another very strong move here how should
white defend in this position
who sees a very annoying move that way
can play here
and this demonstrates the downside of
pushing all of your pawns forward
yeah white plays f3 no this is not
winning or it is winning oh it is
winning but it's only winning because
black has a counter resource
this illustrates
how careful you have to be when your
pawns are deep in your opponent's
territory
no not f4 because of knight takes g4
but knight d4 is the winning move here i
didn't see this
knight d4 yeah attacking the queen
attacking the pawn and if you take then
you get pinned
thank you luke lax for the prime
thank you everybody for the subs i
appreciate it
but the point i'm trying to make is that
if you take on f3 all of a sudden white
converges on this f pawn and the h pawn
is also weak
so you just can't push
random pawns with abandon
what if he took h4 with the pawn yeah
well he could have taken h4
one interesting move here is actually e4
opening up the diagonal for the bishop
and there's a tactic if d takes c4 we
can do this
and then this
and then this
i'm not convinced that this is the most
decisive continuation but that's one
thing we can do
if you want to play it simpler you can
go knight d4 here
and ultimately
as i mentioned earlier notice that the
bishop keeps getting opened up and it's
an absolute beast on this diagonal
so bishop takes h2 works first as well
yeah so g takes h4 would have introduced
you know decisive weaknesses on the king
side
but the move knight d4 is very important
then we go h3
and final moment i want to explain why i
play bishop e7 and not rook h8 so i knew
that in the case of rook h8 and in the
case of bishop b7 white's going to push
the f-bond because that's the only
possible move
there is no other way to defend against
rook takes h4
but what i didn't want to happen i i
wanted to control the e-file
once white pushed the f1 in particular
the e3 square
is an is a huge weakness and i wanted to
have the machinery in place to exploit
it quickly before white can get a rook
to the e-file does that make sense so
for that reason we use the bishop to
accomplish this task getting rid of the
knight
also we can actually physically take the
knight whereas if there was a rook on h8
taking the knight would have involved
sacrificing the exchange
takes now white probably should have
played f3
but it here we can take and even we can
take on f3 and then play rookie two so
this is completely winning as well
takes takes yeah gf3 f4 we take it go
rookie three
probably the last chance for white is to
go rook de1
but here we would have simply doubled
rooks
takes takes
and let's say white plays h5
does anybody see
how black should make progress and this
is
this can be infuriatingly difficult for
some people
for everybody how should black make
progress here
i think there are several winning
approaches
yeah so g3 is possible
g3 is possible
i think the other winning move is queen
e6 you guys are
acing it
so what happens after g3 if white takes
it then we take back and we go rogue g2
on the next move
but what happens if y goes h6
see here actually despite appearances
white's king is still alive
so now you need some finesse in order to
win this position
yeah queen g8 very good i think queen g8
is important because it stops the pawn
it creates an x-ray and it just
creates decisive threats against white's
king
i mean this is over
but the the russian school of chess
would would dictate the move queen e6
just
eliminate the counter play stop the pawn
and then infiltrate with rookie two
over
game is over
so converting these kinds of positions
takes a lot of experience and practice
and and it's not easy
well c3 we played dc
not
forced we also could have played g3 but
dc is the nicest one and rook d3
and it's winning
he could have played c4 at the end but
then we would have taken on passant
same thing
can't take the rook because of checkmate
it simply transposes c3 c4 doesn't
matter
and worse comes to worst we could have
dropped the queen back to c6
worse comes to worse we could have
dropped the queen back to c6 and the
long-term weakness of g2 is totally
decisive
when this situation arises
like the game is totally over
but it's a nice example of transforming
the advantage right we do this in order
to made a munchie too and as a result of
f4 we see ah the e3 square is a new
weakness let's occupy it with our rogue
and win by infiltrating down the e file
any questions about this game
[Music]
you